[Music]
all eyes are on scarlett johansson now
that black widow has finally hit
theaters and disney plus
with black widow natasha romanov has
finally got the
solo film she always deserved which
takes place between the events of 2016's
captain america civil war and
2018's avengers infinity war and while
everyone knows that natasha doesn't make
it out of avengers end game alive
black widow is still a fun ride with a
compelling story
one that also introduces a host of brand
new characters to the marvel cinematic
universe
the film's post-credit scene returns the
story to the present day where the
audience is
painfully reminded yet again that
natasha is no longer with us
as difficult as it is for marvel fans to
relive natasha's death it wasn't as
hard of a pill for johansson to swallow
the actress has been busy promoting her
new film and in an interview with bbc
radio 1
she revealed what it was like to find
out that natasha was going to meet her
demise and end game
of course when the time came to tell
scarlett johansson that black widow was
going to meet her ultimate fate
there was only one person who could make
the call johansson told radio 1 that
marvel studios president kevin feige was
the one who let her know about natasha's
fate
and she admitted he seemed kind of sad
about being the one to tell her
she said i think he was nervous to tell
me and sad about it
saying something along the lines of we
all expected that there would have to be
some big sacrifices
as far as handling the news johansson
apparently took it rather well
she recalled it didn't surprise me that
that was a choice that nat would have
made
i knew that she had to feel at peace
with that decision and that she was
doing it out of love
as gutting as it was to lose natasha an
endgame fans will have to prepare
themselves for a future without
johansen's character
as the actress has revealed she has
absolutely no plans to return to the
role in the future
in an interview with fatherly shortly
after the release of black widow
johansson delivered unsurprising yet
predictable news
that this standalone film is the last
we'll see of this beloved character
she did however hint that her
relationship with marvel is far from
over
johansen said it feels like a great way
to go out for this chapter of my marvel
identity
i would love to be able to continue to
collaborate with marvel in other ways
because i think there's just an
incredible wealth of stories there
though this may be the end of johansen's
tenure as natasha however
that doesn't mean the moniker of black
widow will necessarily be retired going
forward
as fans learned in the film's
post-credits scene yelena belova
mourning the loss of her late adopted
sister
has been driven into action by the
mysterious contessa allegra defontaine
it's entirely likely that elena will
step into natasha's shoes
and take over the mantle in future mcu
projects
natasha herself though leaves behind an
impressive legacy in the mcu
especially considering her origins
johansen herself has even recently
criticized how the character was first
treated when she arrived
in the mcu back in 2010 johansen joined
the superhero franchise in iron man 2
but after fully realizing the character
for years johansson admitted that she's
fairly unhappy with her character's
roots
describing the character's evolution
during a round table discussion with the
press johansson said
i mean you look back at iron man 2 and
while it was really fun and had a lot of
great moments in it
the character is so sexualized you know
that will be all miss freshman thank you
very much
i want one no she went on to say now
people young girls are getting a much
more positive message but it's been
incredible to be a part of that shift
and be able to come out the other side
and be a part of that old story but also
progress
evolve i think it's pretty cool check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]